live four six four three zero eight zero
the crisis years examines the
relationship between president john f
kennedy and soviet leader nikita
khrushchev and its impact on the cold
war its author presidential historian
michael beschloss appeared on book notes
in 1991 to talk about this then newly
published book
michael bechlas author of the new book
the crisis years kennedy and khrushchev
1960 to 1963.
let me read you just a fairly long
paragraph here
page 702 of your book and get your
reaction to it
but throughout his term kennedy rarely
showed the magnaminity
that should have been expected of a
superior power
instead he aroused the western world to
an hour of imminent danger that did not
exist
provoke the adversary by exposing soviet
nuclear weaknesses to the world and
unwittingly caused the soviets to fear
that
he was on the verge of exploiting
american nuclear strength to settle the
cold war on american terms perhaps even
in a preemptive strike
that was the dark side of john kennedy
as a master of foreign policy the
argument i'm making brian is this in
1960 when john kennedy ran for president
over and over again he said the united
states is in imminent danger of falling
into second place behind the russians
now that the cold war is over and we
have a lot more information we know that
the soviet union in 1960 was actually
a fourth rate economic power second-rate
military power had 1 18th the number of
nuclear weapons that we had
so given all that when kennedy came into
power in 1961 he couldn't very well just
say
sorry folks what i said during the
campaign is now inoperative he had to
act on the assumption that not only was
the soviet union an equal but perhaps in
danger of becoming a superior and that
was one of the reasons why these three
years 1960 to 1963 were so dangerous
why did you pick those three years why
not 60 to 64 or 59 to 65 what was it
well the argument i make brian is that
1960 to 1963 was a period that was
absolutely unique
these were the only three years in all
of our experience when americans felt an
imminent danger of dying in a nuclear
war i would argue that that was not true
before 1960 and never happened again
after 1963.
so the question i really wanted to ask
was
why was it what was it about these three
years that made this period so dangerous
was it that the issues between the u.s
and the soviet union were greater or was
it something else and i found it was
something else
how old were you in 1960 and where were
you i was four years old i was living in
illinois and i don't have much memory of
the 1960 campaign but i do have a memory
of later parts of that period the cuban
missile crisis for instance the fall of
62.
we had neighbors in illinois this would
have been about 40 miles south of
chicago who were
building a bomb shelter and we children
were told not to eat the snow because
the russians had put radioactivity in it
so as a child i had a very intense
experience of the crisis years this was
not something that was abstract
how did you
go about finding out
what happened in those years
well the two things that any historian
tries to do is
number one turn up as new as much new
information as you can and number two
explain it and set it in context
new information
in the last couple of years thanks to
mikhail gorbachev you can go to the
soviet union and talk to soviet
officials quite candidly about their
past that wasn't possible before
gorbachev so you have for instance the
testimony of someone like andre gramico
the foreign minister why he lied to
president kennedy in october of 1962 in
saying there were no missiles in cuba
and it's also had an effect on the
american side now that the cold war is
over there are many people in the cia
for instance richard helms who i
interviewed at great length who will
talk a lot more freely than when these
issues were more sensitive
as far as context
now that we're in a post-cold war period
we know how the cold war ended we've had
30 years since the crisis years it's a
lot easier to set this period in
perspective than when it was really an
early chapter of current events you've
been on the tour for how long
ten cities three weeks
as you go about talking about this what
do people want to know
people are fascinated by john kennedy
and this is something that's very unlike
most other presidents usually when about
30 years passed a president is sort of a
figure in history and not really a live
presence
john kennedy is someone who to this day
stirs up a great deal of controversy
people are very polarized
people who
love john kennedy don't see flaws in him
and also many people who hate him very
few in the middle and that's one reason
why in this book i've tried very much to
walk down the middle and show
both his strengths and also his
weaknesses and present as
three-dimensional a picture of john
kennedy as i possibly could have you
gotten any sense from the call-in shows
you've been on in other interviews
whether or not
president kennedy is up or down in the
eyes of most americans
i think it's very polarized you know you
have segments that feel very intensely
i think you you saw a period just in
terms of the historiography of kennedy
after his tragic death needless to say
you you saw many books written that were
extremely reverential many people like
mcgeorge bundy who did not wrote write a
book but wrote an article at the time
bundy was kennedy's national security
adviser he says that those who were
around kennedy and who wrote books and
articles in the year after years after
the assassination were a little bit too
reverential
then beginning in the middle of the
1970s you had such things as the church
committee of the senate that
investigated john kennedy's possible
involvement in assassination plots and
also the possible security risks that
were caused by his private life that
caused the historiography the things
written on john kennedy to take another
very sharp turn
i don't know of any president brian
where you've seen such enormous zigzags
in his reputation how do you feel about
it i feel that i try to walk really down
the middle i think this is someone who
is a tremendous crisis manager i think
you have to remember that
given the fact that 61 and 62 and 63
were so dangerous especially over berlin
and cuba if it were not for john
kennedy's very careful management of
those crises you might have seen 200
million human beings die i think he also
was probably
the most or one of the most intelligent
presidents of this century
at the same time on the downside i don't
rate him very high on crisis avoidance
as i show in the book these crises i
think did not have to happen and simply
because that many people did not die
does not mean that we can entirely
forgive either kennedy or chris jaw for
keeping the world on the brink for three
years
one of the things that struck me as i
read it were there were parallels
between president kennedy and chairman
khrushchev and the one simple parallel
that president kennedy one of his chief
aides was his brother bobby
and one of
mr khrushchev's chief advisers was his
son-in-law talk about the son-in-law
or frankly you haven't told us what you
thought of mr kruschev and also about
bobby kennedy those three men well there
was an enormous parallel between john
kennedy and nikita khrushchev these were
two men who both distrusted the foreign
service bureaucracy
and instead relied on back channels one
of the stories that runs throughout the
book is the relationship that khrushchev
had named with a man named georgie
boshikoff
bolshakov was a soviet military
intelligence agent who was based in the
embassy in washington he was under what
they call shallow cover as a press
attache he was a friend of khrushchev's
son a man named alexay ajoubei
bolshakov appeared in robert kennedy's
office in may of 1961
said essentially you don't know me but i
can get secret messages to and from
khrushchev very quickly the first
message he sent in may of 1961 was mr
khrushchev wants a summit that led to
the summit between kennedy and
khrushchev in vienna of june of 1961.
so you see brian a lot of the
relationship between kennedy and
khrushchev two men both distrustful in
kennedy's case of his state department
both very eager to work through other
channels let me just interrupt a second
uh this is mr azubay this is azubei who
came to see john kennedy in january of
1962 and that's what that is that is a
picture of who's the woman living that
is his wife that is nikita khrushchev's
daughter rada and she is wearing a mink
coat for which she got a lot of
criticism at the time she was the
daughter of a leader who tried to live
rather modestly i'm sorry i interrupted
your train of thought not a bit
john kennedy like khrushchev also wanted
to work through a channel that he could
depend on and robert kennedy beginning
about the same time spring of 1961
began to act as john kennedy's back
channel to the cia
what richard helms of the cia calls john
kennedy's wire brush man so much of the
history of this period you see
robert kennedy calling second and third
level officials in the cia
especially about cuba saying the
president is very upset he wants castro
out of havana castro is still there what
are you going to do about it
you mentioned early about new
information looking for new information
what do you consider to be the most
significant new information you've got
in this book
i think the main new information is what
the soviets were doing through this
period
for example
we have seen the cuban missile crisis
and i saw it at the time as a child as
sort of a passion play
that nikita khrushchev for sinister
reasons that we couldn't understand
out of the blue move missiles into cuba
john kennedy demanded that he take them
out the missiles went out and that was
the end of it
what i found from my soviet interviews
was that the reality was a little bit
more complex the people who were around
khrushchev say that in early 1962
khrushchev was very worried about
something named operation mongoose this
was 33 different covert operations waged
by the cia against cuba
sabotage poisoning of sugar exports
shooting from motorboats and also
efforts to assassinate fidel castro
castro and khrushchev thought that
operation mongoose was the forerunner to
an american invasion of cuba with full
u.s military force
probably in the fall of 1962
it turns out that castro and khrushchev
put their heads together asking the
question
what can we possibly do that will thwart
this american invasion of cuba the
answer that they came up with was put in
nuclear missiles
a picture here of mr khrushchev and
dean rusk
you paint a picture of dean rusk in this
book that i'll let you describe
dean rusk was not a very happy secretary
of state during the crisis years
this is someone who did not know john
kennedy really before he was appointed
in december of 1960. john kennedy wanted
to act very much as his own secretary of
state and what you see through this
period and we've seen it certainly in
other administrations is
john kennedy and others in the white
house
making an effort to circumvent rusk
use other channels such as robert
kennedy george bundy the national
security adviser and other people who
were more kennedy men
what really happened particularly to
rusk was that he fell a foul of robert
kennedy robert kennedy thought that rusk
was more loyal to the state department
than to john kennedy there was very
fierce tension between robert kennedy
and dean rusk throughout these years
a line in your epilogue returning from a
saigon trip in march
and this was in 1964 i believe
mcnamara recommended new assistance to
south vietnam that brought up the name
of robert mcnamara what do you think of
him and what role did he play in the
vietnam war
robert kennedy or i should say robert
mcnamara the secretary of defense
absolutely captivated kennedy kennedy
was very taken by him and in fact one of
the things i show in the book is that
john kennedy very seriously considered
naming robert mcnamara as his successor
as president assuming that he served two
terms and was able to name his successor
at the democratic convention of 1968.
mcnamara was a businessman
very hard to get those for democratic
administrations in those days was
extremely articulate very sharp
dominated almost any meeting he entered
kennedy's people were a little bit
worried about mcnamara they felt that
sometimes he was so forceful so
persuasive that
he was able to get john kennedy to do
things that he shouldn't have
on the question of vietnam what this
particularly raises as you suggest is
the question of
what john kennedy might have done had he
lived and had to make the same decision
on vietnam that lyndon johnson did many
have said that john kennedy
said in 1963 privately i want to get
reelected first then when i come back to
power i'll get our troops out of vietnam
i tend to find that not very persuasive
for two reasons number one is kennedy
would have been advised by exactly the
same people especially robert mcnamara
who advised lyndon johnson in 1965
to plunge deeply into vietnam
and the other reason brian is that
i think it takes some cynicism to assume
that john kennedy would have kept
thousands of americans in south vietnam
in harm's way getting killed
only to pull them out in 1965
after allowing them to be killed for
essentially domestic reasons the winning
of the 1964 election was it robert
mcnamara that asked
president kennedy or somebody did you
really write profiles and courage before
he took the job
he did he met with john kennedy whom he
did not know in georgetown at john
kennedy's house in 1960 and mcnamara i
think a because he's a forceful person
and b because perhaps he knew that
kennedy would be impressed said before i
agree to be your secretary of defense i
want two things number one i'd like to
know if you really wrote profiles in
courage kennedy said that he did and
number two i'd like written assurance
that you're going to give me full
independence as secretary of defense
that i can name my own people kennedy
gave him that
you say you grew up in illinois where
grew up born in chicago
lived in chicago for my first five years
and then lived in a town called
flossmoor which is at the
south end of cook county
in fact the county that john kennedy
credited with giving him the 1960
election what did your parents do
my father was a businessman my mother
was a homemaker i guess one would say
not terribly politically involved
although my father was the president of
the school board in town and where did
you go to school meaning college i went
to college in massachusetts at williams
college and went to graduate school at
harvard what got you interested in
history
was interested in history from the time
i was a small boy and in fact the first
serious book of all things i ever read
was arthur schlesinger's a thousand days
at the age of ten i never thought it
would be useful later on to having uh
having read it
but i think one thing brian and you're
from the midwest too
unlike people who live in the east i
think people who grew up in the midwest
to some extent have the sense that
historical events are somewhat detached
from them
i for instance had never met someone who
had written a book until i was probably
15 years old had not met people who were
in political life until i was about that
age that is an experience i think
someone who lives in the east would be
less likely to have so i think reading
about these events made me very
interested in how they take place and
want to write about them later on did
you
what got you interested in a thousand
days and arthur schlesinger why did you
read that book do you have any yeah i do
i was very interested in john kennedy
and as a matter of fact he was one of my
childhood heroes when he died i wrote a
letter to president johnson
uh asking him to hire a large carving
firm to carve president kennedy's head
at mount rushmore and i got a reply from
johnson's secretary saying thank you for
the advice and i can remember taking the
reply to my friends at the ice skating
rink in town they all thought it was a
forgery years later when i was doing
work in the johnson library i said
i'm sure you won't have this but maybe
you keep some children's letters and in
about five minutes they were able to
pull it out so i have a xerox of the
original letter your first book kennedy
and roosevelt the uneasy alliance 1980
was about what that was on the
relationship between john kennedy's
father joseph kennedy senior and
franklin roosevelt which was actually my
original undergraduate honors thesis at
williams college in massachusetts
was interested in those two characters
because i was very interested in
political leadership
joseph kennedy and franklin roosevelt
were people who were about the same age
and in the 1920s it had
business careers during that period in
american business that was not terribly
unlike the 1950s and the 1980s periods
in which business was very dominant in
our culture
and then were in politics of course in
the 30s and 40s
kennedy was wonderful in business made a
great fortune roosevelt went through a
number of schemes to make money and
almost always lost money in every one
yet of course when roosevelt went back
into politics in the 1930s was one of
our greatest presidents and had this
very strange relationship with joseph
kennedy that culminated in joseph
kennedy's ambassadorship in the early
period of world war ii your second book
may day uh eisenhower khrushchev and u2
and the u2 affair 1986. why'd you do
that one
that was a book that was really dealing
with the late years of the eisenhower
period
and as a diplomatic historian you really
want to work with fresh material that
was a book that was written in the early
1980s and the most recent documents that
were
being unsealed under the freedom of
information act were documents from the
late eisenhower period so that was a
situation in which i was able to take
fresh material and interpret it for
perhaps the first time
what do you do besides write books
i write books about 95 percent of the
time i've been a treasurer of a small
foundation the penn faulkner foundation
here in washington and also the director
of a program
funded by the annenberg foundation on
the impact of television on american
foreign policy
when did you start writing or gathering
information for this current book
started the crisis years in 1985
and that was a time when you simply
assumed that you were not able to get
soviet sources when i was writing may
day i would write to various soviet
figures quite dutifully and i would get
letters back saying mrs khrushchev has
been consulted and does not wish to be
interviewed at this time well that was
not unusual because mrs khrushchev never
wished to be interviewed she wasn't
allowed to be and i sometimes joke that
things have changed so much that if mrs
khrushchev were still alive i would get
a letter back from her lecture agent
saying that her hotel suite had to be
equipped with guava juice and that she
would demand a very high price
this book has 816 pages
i counted them up i can't find the page
where the number of pages of notes and
indexes and all that come up to about
100 pages
when do you decide how big a book's
going to be and this book sells for
29.95 i assume there's a lot you left
out
there is i think the the largest
responsibility i had on this book brian
was to write a book that really could
accommodate the new information i think
if there hadn't been that new
information i've referred to from the
soviet union from the cia on this side
and from a lot of other american german
and soviet figures who were willing to
speak quite candidly these days it would
have been a much shorter book since i
was turning up a lot of new information
that was not yet in the public domain i
wanted to write a book that was as
consistently surprising and fresh as
possible
and it really took 800 pages to do it
the most valuable source
the most valuable source i think was
as a body these interviews in the soviet
union because this really
increased
entirely
by a hundred percent the amount of
information we had on the soviet side
you could find out for instance what
khrushchev was saying to his son
during the months before the cuban
missile crisis
what he and the east germans were
telling each other during the weeks
leading up to the berlin wall
how he greeted the news of john
kennedy's
pigs invasion it turned out that it
happened on khrushchev's birthday he was
sitting in his indoor outdoor pool on
his estate in the black sea and he said
this is a very surprising birthday
present
i don't want you to give away your
secret techniques but uh when you want
to go look for information in the soviet
union how do you do it well you do it in
a number of ways one is you simply write
to people and interview them for
instance i talked to sergey kristoff who
was nikita khrushchev's son and who came
to the united states for the first time
in 1989
the first time that since the famous
trip he took with his father in 1959
when they toured this country and went
to hollywood and finally nikita
khrushchev met with eisenhower camp
david
the other source that's very important
is that these people now are very eager
to write memoirs in magazines newspapers
and also in book form sergey christian
for instance published a volume of
memoirs last year
alexei azubay the son-in-law of
christchuff has been serially publishing
his memoirs in his vestia which in the
early 1960s was the paper of which he
was editor do you speak russian
i don't and as a matter of fact before a
couple of years ago it probably wouldn't
have hurt me because you were dealing
mainly with reading between the lines of
pravda and that you could get translated
as it turns out it hasn't hurt me that
much with this because most of the
people i would have wanted to interview
have a pretty good command of english
but i think any historian who wants
wants to write american soviet history
in the future i think will have to have
a very good command of russian what is
sergey khrushchev like and how old is he
and where does he live he is in his late
50s he is living in moscow
he looks actually not unlike his father
although he's a little bit thinner
and he had a very poignant experience
this is someone who during his father's
reign until 1964 was treated something
like a crown prince
lived in a way that was very lavish
although he's a somewhat modest person
was treated extremely well
one of the stories that i have in the
book is the story of the fact that in
the fall of 1964 he was given
information that there was a coup d'etat
plot against nikita khrushchev and that
chairman khrushchev had better watch out
that put sergey into a little bit of a
dilemma because he and his father had an
arrangement they would never talk about
business he would not presume to
advise his father about matters of state
finally he swallowed his doubts told
khrushchev that there was this plot
afoot this was september of 1964.
khrushchev checked into it and said this
is absurd sergey the people that you're
talking about all hate each other
they're not going to deal with each
other in a coup d'etat i'm not going to
take it seriously a month later those
people actually did combine they threw
khrushchev out of power
this is who you dedicate the book to in
the front who is this and how do you
pronounce it uh it's offsane mashayekhi
she is a distinguished iranian economist
at the world bank and a very close
friend of mine and put up with me during
the years of writing this book
how do you write
where do you write i mean what's the
system that you use because one of the
things that i noticed in reading this is
that
it and this is probably not a fair
comparison but in reading the commanders
by bob woodward you saw the quote marks
and
you know and in order to find out where
these quote marks come from you've got
to go all the way to the back here and
look in the notes tell us about that
technique how does a historian do that
well i think first of all brian
a book a work of history and bob
woodward's book would be contemporary
journalism but a book of history 30
years later
has to really be able to stand up to the
test of sources i think if you don't
have a very clear idea as a reader where
the material book in the book comes from
you don't know whether to take it
seriously or not so every sentence in
the book is
documented i say where it comes from
usually from documents i try not to rely
to rely on interviews i much prefer to
rely on for instance the contemporary
record of the kennedy and chris job
summit
the transcript that was made that is
something that was sealed for all these
years until about seven months ago it
was unsealed just in time to put into
this book
so i think what you try to do or at
least what i try to do is
take as much new material as you
possibly can and in my case i'm a
narrative historian i tell this in terms
of a story
to some extent using fictional
techniques although every syllable in
the book is fact
i think that you can take great
personalities such as the cast of
characters in this book people like
robert kennedy and lyndon johnson and
andrei gramico and others
and give it almost the texture of a
story with a great theme in this case
the three years during which the world
was almost incinerated yet at the same
time cause this all to remain within the
constraints of very documentable fact
page 615
by pursuing women
whose full backgrounds he evidently
could not know kennedy caused his
presidency to be a potential hostage to
any resourceful group in american
society that might have wished to bring
him down the teamsters the mafia the
radical right and every hostile
intelligence service in the world
what is that all about
well any historian has to deal with the
question of john kennedy's private life
as an historian i'm not particularly
fascinated by what he did in his bedroom
but as someone who's writing about his
diplomacy i have to deal with the
question of whether this ever threatened
to affect him as a world leader and the
answer i think has to be yes
every piece of information we have
suggests that the
women that john kennedy was involved
with were not subjected to some kind of
a background investigation
what that meant was that he was very
vulnerable to getting involved with
women who might have been involved with
some kind of an organization that might
wish to blackmail him for its own
purposes we know from the senate
investigation of the mid-1970s for
instance that john kennedy was involved
with a woman named judith exner who was
at the same time involved with sam
giancana who was an underworld organized
crime leader in chicago
at the same time during this period we
know that soviet intelligence was trying
very hard to sexually compromise western
leaders we know as a fact for instance
that they succeeded during this period
with the soviet ambassador from france
or i should say the french ambassador to
moscow
also the british defense minister in
1963
john perfumo who shared a woman
christine keeler with a member of the
soviet embassy he had to resign so the
point i would make here brian is that
this was not just a free floating
anxiety this is something that could
have happened and i think as a
diplomatic historian john kennedy should
have been more careful
let me pursue this a little more because
you suggest that at any time any of
these people could have blackmailed him
why didn't they
that's one of the great 64 thousand
dollar questions
they didn't i think perhaps because of
there wasn't the motive i mean it's hard
to get into the head of someone like
giancana or the soviet intelligence
service but i think for a diplomatic
historian all you have to do is
establish the risk as long as that risk
remained then really the country was at
risk because i would argue that if john
kennedy for instance had been revealed
to have been involved with someone who
was linked to soviet intelligence and
this may have been true
not only would he probably have had to
resign amid a sex and security scandal
very much like the christine keeler
scandal in great britain in
1963 but it would have had a very
poisonous effect on the politics of this
country
other leaders would have been suspect
people would have said did john kennedy
for instance pull his punches at the bay
of pigs because he was under some kind
of compromise by soviet intelligence it
would have been a very ugly atmosphere
did you just discover any new
information
related to the judith campbell
affair that he had and sam giancana
i cover it and the tricky part of this
here is that
judith campbell at the time that she was
involved with kennedy was involved with
giancana who had been hired by the cia
to try to murder fidel castro the
question is whether there was a link
between kennedy and giancana on the
murder of castro i've not found evidence
of this and i've tried to be as
absolutely careful as i could in
separating the wheat from the chaff what
we can be sure of what we cannot be sure
of all right let me see if i can
understand this sam giancana had been uh
he was the leader of the mafia in
chicago in chicago had been hired by the
cia to take out fidel castro that is a
story that we do know for certain in
1960 he was approached by officials of
the cia who essentially said
we know that you have associates in cuba
because the mafia was very involved in
cuba before castro it was estimated that
the mafia was taking in a billion
dollars a year from their concessions in
havana and elsewhere on the island the
mafia said we would like you to use your
acquaintances to kill castro
this plot went on through 1961 and 1962
i interviewed richard helms who was in
charge of it for the cia he says that by
the end of 1962 he did not have very
much more hope that the mafia was able
to
kill castro he felt that if they hadn't
succeeded by then they never would and
in fact some of the teams that were sent
in he felt were probably cast captured
by the castro regime he felt that it was
worthwhile pursuing the plot however
because he wanted to see what kind of
assets the mob might have in cuba that
might be useful to the cia all right sam
giancana and judy campbell
soon to become exner
were lovers
at the same time that the president
kennedy and judy campbell were together
by the evidence that came up during the
senate investigations of the mid-1970s
what i'm getting at though the behind
all this was at the time was bobby
kennedy and the justice department
pursuing
the mob
he was in fact he pursued the mob much
more energetically than any previous
attorney general and so what this raises
of course is
whether
the mob expected to get better treatment
from the kennedy administration because
they felt themselves to be doing these
favors for the cia which was under
president kennedy and whether they were
outraged at the fact that many mafia
leaders were being very energetically
sent to jail by robert kennedy another
uh liaison you write about here is ellen
fimmel
how do you pronounce that romance
romance
the reason i bring that one up is that
she was a 27 year old wife of a west
german airman attached to the west
german military mission in washington
but later on you get into the fact that
senators mansfield and dirksen got into
this act tell us that story
well this comes from fbi files that have
been opened only uh in the last several
years and i might parenthetically say
that
fbi files turn out to be
a very interesting source for the
historian you have to be very careful
because in some cases
fbi files will have reports that are
from unreliable sources and you've got
to take those with a grain of salt
in other cases you have a situation
where
there are wiretaps on telephones and you
get an exact account of a conversation
none of us historians would uh ever
expected that judger hoover the director
of the fbi would turn out to be so
useful to us of course that was not his
purpose
in the summer of 1963
hoover went to robert kennedy and said
we have information that not only your
brother the president but others in
washington have been involved with the
woman whom we suspect as a soviet
intelligence
agent someone who is linked to east
german intelligence
robert kennedy took it seriously enough
that he acted very quickly to control
the damage he spoke with the two leaders
of the senate dirksen and mansfield the
republican and democrat asked them to
keep to themselves whatever knowledge
they had of this he also had the woman
expelled from this country within a week
flown to west germany she was put in a
house that was surrounded by guards to
keep people away
and so whatever scandal might have
occurred did not occur this was a crisis
that was basically kept under control
but the historian once again has to say
that that very well could have become
public it very nearly did
had it done so you could very well have
had a red scare in this country that
would have dwarfed the joseph mccarthy
period were you also saying here that j
edgar hoover had an enormous amount of
power because he had this information
that he could use against the president
at any time absolutely and we know from
history that j edgar hoover was not
loathe to use negative
files against presidents and senators
and others for his own purposes
one more once before a romance had
threatened kennedy's career it was in
early 1942 as a naval intelligence
officer that he was involved with inga
arvid
feijos
a married woman and a reputed recent
mistress of alex werner gren a swede
blacklisted by the state department for
his close association with hermann
gearing
what's that about well the reason why i
found john kennedy's failure to be a
little bit more careful about women he
saw while president was because once
before
during world war ii he had come very
near to having his career ended by a
liaison with someone who is under
suspicion of being an agent this is a
woman who at the time was
under suspicion by the fbi and franklin
roosevelt's attorney general of being a
nazi agent in washington
fbi files recently unsealed which i use
in the book show that she went around
washington
declaiming what she referred to as the
damn dirty jews that she had been
involved with hitler circle in the mid
1930s
john kennedy at the time was a
lieutenant in naval intelligence this
was after pearl harbor
it's hard to say that a 25 year old man
did not know what it meant to be in
intelligence and have an affair with a
woman who was suspected of being a nazi
spy
the fbi files demonstrate that he was
aware of this he wrote letters which
appear in the files referring to her as
a spy in a sort of joking fashion
if all this were
known during or before the kennedy
election years
would it have damaged him back then and
would you think he would have still been
elected president i think it would be
very unlikely that john kennedy would
have become president in 1960 had this
information become known
and what is the reaction on the part of
the public
sense and some of this is new
information as i understand in your book
yes uh part of its prurient bryant for
instance when the book came out there
were two associated press stories about
the book one was on this material the
other was on my new findings on the bay
of pigs the berlin wall and the cuban
missile crisis the first article was
picked up by about 1200 newspapers the
second article by a number that was
radically less than that
i think the more serious reaction is
that it has to come into our assessment
of john kennedy this is someone who as
i've said has enormous has had enormous
strengths did a great deal for this
country during these years yet at the
same time there was a side of him that
caused him to do things that really he
shouldn't have and could have threatened
the political system
these are odds and ends things i wanted
to ask you about as i read the book
nikita khrushchev spent 25 days in this
country at one point yes that was during
the campaign of 1960 nikita khrushchev
felt that
he felt that he could have some
influence over who became president in
1960
he took a boat over to new york and
spent that many days in new york in this
country and at the u.n that was when he
had the famous incident when he beat his
shoe on the table
as a matter of fact one of the things i
found out from soviet sources
this has always been taken as an example
of what a buffoon and crude person
khrushchev was
it turns out that it was a planned
gesture
khrushchev in the u.n was trying to
create a sense of solidarity with many
third world nations the proletariat of
these nations he felt that a gesture
like this that was somewhat peasant-like
would win him a few friends
and as it turns out much of the 1960
campaign was fought over the issue as
kennedy and nixon said of who could
stand up to khrushchev that was very
unlike 1952 you did not have eisenhower
and adlai stevenson
but competing on the basis of who could
stand up to stalin
you
write a lot or you referenced a lot
about john kennedy's back pain what kind
of uh
effect did that have on him
in may of 1961 john kennedy re-injured
his bad back in a tree planting ceremony
in canada
it put him in a very difficult situation
because
he was planning to meet nikita
khrushchev at a summit in vienna at the
beginning of june
he said privately as i have in the book
i don't want to go see khrushchev as a
[ __ ] on crutches he had to act fast
as it turns out in order to
fix his back trouble he resorted to a
doctor in new york called max jacobson
who we now look on as a not very
serious or responsible doctor someone
who experimented with amphetamines put a
lot of things in his hypodermic needles
that most doctors would not consider to
be a very good thing
as it turns out kennedy had this doctor
flown to vienna he injected kennedy
on some occasions during the
intermissions between his meetings with
khrushchev
i was interested as an historian
whether this affected kennedy's
performance amphetamines can make you go
up and down can make you garrulous or
sometimes make you very low
from the transcripts of the vienna
meetings there is no sense that kennedy
was affected by these amphetamines this
was a gamble that he took in one was
president kennedy fatalistic
he was fatalistic in certain ways in
managing for instance the berlin crisis
and the cuban missile crisis you will
see no president who is more responsible
human missile crisis for instance we
know because he made secret tapes of the
meetings in the cabinet room and you
could listen to them as i did and i put
a lot of the dialogue in this book this
is someone who asked excellent questions
was very much hands-on there was no
question who is in charge
but john kennedy was fatalistic in two
ways as i write in the book
one was with women as i say he took
chances that could have had national
security implications chances i think he
shouldn't have taken
another way he was fatalistic was he was
very interested in death george smathers
the senator from florida and a great
friend of kennedy told me in an
interview that 20 times or more john
kennedy would say to him
what do you think is the best way to die
is it better to get shot is it better to
drown is it better to die slowly so that
you could have some time to think about
it
i think both of these forms of fatalism
had to do with the fact that in john
kennedy's early life he was under the
impression that he would die at an early
age from addison's disease this is
something that he suffered from until
about 1950 it was almost always fatal
and that was a time when he formed uh
essentially this personal policy of
living for the moment because tomorrow
you die
you
talk about two newsmen in here that were
deeply involved in
americanism in a liaison
one of them john scali with abc news and
was our un ambassador the story is
fairly well known although you suggest
that uh you found out that maybe that
story wasn't really
he didn't play as big a role as we think
he played yes i think john scalia is
absolutely right in what he said all
these years which is that during the
cuban missile crisis he
met with a soviet intelligence official
named alexander fomeen those meetings i
am certain took place at the occidental
restaurant at the occidental restaurant
the predecessor of the occidental
restaurant that is now here in
washington
but at the same time what scally could
not know was
who authorized for mean to
have these meetings if anyone and what
importance they had in moscow
what we now know from soviet sources as
i write in the book is that
far from being authorized by khrushchev
which is the impression that
scully had of for me and also the
americans who knew about these meetings
fomen was freelancing
people in the soviet embassy during the
cuban missile crisis in washington had
been told basically to try it to get as
much information as you possibly can
and faumine was an example of this
and it turns out that the information he
sent back to moscow
arrived at times that would not have
influenced important decisions so it
turns out to be an incident interesting
vignette but i think not one that really
changed the course of history frank
holman new york daily news who was he
and why do you why did you write so much
about him frank holman is still living
as far as i know he was a wine house
correspondent for the new york daily
news in the early 60s
he was approached by the gentleman i
referred to earlier georgie boshikov
this soviet intelligence agent in
washington whom he knew he was on the
board of the national press club new
bolshokov through the press club
bolshakov came to holman and said i want
to meet with robert kennedy i know that
you know him and you've covered him
perhaps you could introduce me and it
was holman who made the introduction
that led to the first meeting between
robert kennedy and bolshakov in may of
1961. were you surprised at how active a
role that a news person would have
played in that process
yes and to use news people as
intermediaries holman and scally and
others i think shows really how
different the crisis years were from our
own time nowadays president bush can
pick up a telephone and call mr
gorbachev in the early 60s kennedy and
khrushchev were reduced to
sending secret messages through newsmen
through intelligence agents in fact
boshikov would sometimes meet members of
the kennedy administration on street
corners or in saloons he would pass them
a newspaper inside the newspaper was a
secret private message from khrushchev
to kennedy this was a very dicey way to
conduct international relations another
odds and ends continuing
somewhere i read
and it had quote marks around it
that adlai stevenson couldn't control
the smile on his face at the death the
notice of the death of john kennedy
that's poignant
the night of the death of john kennedy
arthur schlesinger says he saw stevenson
at the white house and he said stevenson
had a smile on his face schlesinger who
had worked for stevenson in his
campaigns in the 1950s said i never felt
the same way about stevenson after that
the relationship between john kennedy
and adlai stevenson is something i go
into a great deal in this book stevenson
of course had been the nominee of the
democratic party in the 50s was still in
1961 when john kennedy became president
probably the most popular democrat in
the country more popular among democrats
than kennedy was kennedy was very eager
to cut stevenson down to size he didn't
want him as a rival he also knew that
stevenson could be very dangerous if
stevenson whom he had appointed
ambassador to the united nations should
ever decide to resign in protest over a
kennedy policy
i think another part of this was that
kennedy felt very emotionally about
stevenson kennedy was not someone who
was without a streak of cruelty and he
did a number of things to make stevenson
feel small
and essentially as i i say cut him down
to size what'd you think of governor
stevenson
as an illinoisian i would be a great
stevenson fan and stevenson's name is
almost holy in illinois i would say that
his years in the kennedy administration
were
very poignant very sad
a time in which someone who is used to
being the center of attention with a
great deal of influence was a member of
administration that did not like him did
not consult him played cruel tricks on
him
who are some of the people that you got
to know in your research for this book
that were around the kennedy
administration that surprised you as to
how interesting they were some people we
haven't talked about one example was
mcgeorge bundy who was kennedy's
national security advisor and is now
a writer and scholar on the history of
nuclear weapons he is someone who has a
wonderful sense of humor very smart a
very useful
instrument of kennedy's diplomacy
another one that i've interviewed is
richard helms who as i've suggested
earlier now that the cold war is over
we'll speak very freely about many
subjects that would have been very
sensitive during this period not least
his involvement in the assassination
attempts against castro and that raises
sort of a very sensitive and interesting
problem brian and that is that for all
these years there's been an effort by
people to establish whether or not john
kennedy knew of and approved of the
assassination attempts by the cia
against castro helms has always been in
a very difficult position because
he prides himself on on being the man
who kept the secrets as a biography of
him was once entitled someone who has
not betrayed the faith that he feels
that he had as a cia official at the
same time many people around john
kennedy have made the argument kennedy
would never have approved of these
milita of these murder attempts against
castro the cia was going off on its own
on a rogue operation helms will not say
that kennedy approved them yet at the
same time i would say that he is at
least
to some extent justifiably irritated
with the fact that the kennedy people
blame him for something that he feels
john kennedy authorized
one thing i found in my interviews
george smathers told me that a month
before the bay of pigs invasion in the
spring of 61 kennedy told him there is
an effort to murder castro that i know
about this is to take place just before
a thousand cuban exiles trained by the
cia hit the beaches of cuba trying to
overthrow
the cuban government if castro is killed
just before those men hit the beaches
there will be chaos and pandemonium they
will have a good chance of succeeding
that to some extent answers the question
of why kennedy authorized this very
small ragtag group of invaders that
otherwise would seem to have been
impossible to succeed in invading cuba
how close did we come to
nuclear war
we came very close throughout the whole
period especially in 1961 over berlin
nikita khrushchev threatened a number of
times to take over berlin we the united
states and the west had promised that we
would go to the point of nuclear war to
resist that we were very close then
second time was during the cuban missile
crisis october of 62 the joint chiefs of
staff had resolved if an american plane
were downed in cuba during that crisis
we would automatically bomb the soviet
missile sites it took john kennedy to
stand up against the joint chiefs and
say no
had he not stood up those sites would
have been bombed russians would have
been killed nikita khrushchev would have
been under enormous pressure to
retaliate against the united states
another interesting
scene was
when mr khrushchev i know i'm jumping
all over the place here but uh there's
so much it's a big book uh when mr
kershaf
got bounced from
being the chairman of the party in the
soviet union can you
build that little scenario around and
how did he
you touched on what his son had told him
that there was a threat against him but
what actually happened and how did he
find out that his days were over well i
think it starts really with a whole
history of his last year which began
with john kennedy's assassination when
kennedy was killed in dallas the c.i.a
tried to locate christia they couldn't
find him there was some worry that
khrushchev was in a bomb shelter
somewhere outside moscow bracing for
american retaliation for soviet
involvement in kennedy's murder and
khrushchev in fact rushed the next day
the day after the assassination to the
u.s ambassador in moscow and said you
must believe me i was not behind this
kennedy's death removed the argument
that khrushchev had made with his own
people that you must keep me in power
i'm indispensable because i have this
wonderful relationship with the american
president once john kennedy died he
could no longer say that and there was a
coup d'etat in 1964 led by leonid
brezhnev and this we only now know from
soviet sources
not only did brezhnev want to take
khrushchev out of power and replace him
he also wanted to kill him he went to
the director of the kgb during that
period and said khrushchev is scheduled
to fly from cairo to moscow why don't
you put a bomb aboard the plane
then brezhnev thought better of the idea
not because he felt any more sentimental
about khrushchev but because andre
gramico the foreign minister was on that
plane brezhnev figured that he would
need grameko when he came to power
the result was that in october of 1964
brezhnev and other people who khrushchev
thought to be his closest allies
joined together chris jaw flew from the
black sea to moscow appeared at a
meeting in the kremlin they told him he
was out
he begged to be appointed at least
minister of agriculture he did not want
to give up power they told him
essentially forget it and that was the
end of khrushchev he lived until 1971 in
a small house he was given outside
moscow he was massively depressed this
was a man who was very used to power to
isolate him for seven years was almost
the worst thing you could do
the picture that you paint though is mr
khrushchev being at his dacha or
wherever he was and getting a phone call
from the
the pull-up bureau that's right and
saying you come to you come to moscow he
was told to come to moscow and
khrushchev in his normally high-handed
way said you know can't you deal with
this when i get back to moscow
next month
nothing should be so important that i
have to interrupt my vacation they told
him that he'd better come now
he was flown to moscow he got off the
plane rather than the usual welcoming
delegation the only one who was there
was the chairman of the kgb and he had
christoff driven to this meeting in
moscow question today with mr gorbachev
could that same thing happen
no
this coup d'etat depended on the fact
that leaders of the soviet union in the
early 1960s were selected by a very
small group
if that small group turned against you
you were out
a small group of the same kind tried to
throw khrushchev out once before in 1957
and almost succeeded these coup
unusual in those days nowadays as the
soviet union becomes more pluralistic
and more people have a say in who
becomes not only the leader of the
soviet union but leaders of the
republics it's going to be a lot harder
for a group of six men to come together
and simply say you are no longer
employed in the kremlin is there any new
information to still find out about
nikita khrushchev
there is it is said that khrushchev's
papers were destroyed just after
khrushchev was taken out of power by the
order of leonid brezhnev brezhnev knew
that khrushchev was still very popular
among the soviet people he wanted to
wipe out any trace of khrushchev
and therefore not only had apparently
his papers destroyed but also had uh the
soviet press and soviet publishing and
other officials refuse ever to mention
the name and christian the name
khrushchev in public and therefore
between 1964 and recent years you've had
a whole generation of soviet citizens
growing up who have never heard
christoph's name mentioned is sergey
khrushchev the sun's book credible
yes it was written about two years ago
and it was vetted translated and edited
by an eminent skull american scholar of
soviet affairs are the khrushchev uh
memoirs credible the khrushchev memoirs
there was some talk when they were
published this was khrushchev talking
into a tape recorder the tapes were
smuggled to the west and published in
1970 1974. there was some talk at the
time there was there was rarely any
doubt that this was actually
khrushchev's voice
there was some talk of the time that as
the price of getting the memoirs out he
was forced to put in some disinformation
that would throw off western
intelligence
my take on them now is that he told the
truth as he knew it but khrushchev's
view in many cases was very distorted he
also didn't have access to his own
records your next book
my next book is on bush and gorbachev
which i am writing in collaboration with
a journalist strobe talbot of time
magazine we are aspiring to write an
account of how this relationship has
developed between these two leaders
between 1989 and 1992 based on
interviews with soviets and americans
were expecting it to come out in the
fall of 1992. and last question are you
happy with the way this book's played
out and the way it's being
bought and read
i have
this is a book that in many ways very
much disagrees with
much of what has been written about the
history of the crisis years over the
last 30 years
many of the people who have reviewed it
have been people whose work i have to
some extent revised based on both new
information and also additional
perspective
and they've treated it respectfully and
for that i'm grateful michael bechlas
author of the crisis years
kennedy and khrushchev 1960 to 1963.
thank you for joining us thank you brian
michael beschloss is the author of
several books on the american presidency
he's also a regular commentator on the
pbs program the newshour with jim lehrer
his book the crisis years kennedy and
khrushchev was published in 1991 by
harper trade
mr beschloss is one of the six
contributors to power in the presidency
published by public affairs books
every weekend book tv brings you an
encore presentation of c-span's book
notes program encore book notes airs
saturdays at 7 p.m and sundays at 11 a.m
eastern here on c-span 2.
next week an encore book notes interview
with former soviet leader mikhail
gorbachev his book memoirs recounts his
career as a communist party leader
you can find complete schedule
information on our website
booktv.org
click on encore book notes for video
clips of upcoming programs and
highlights from c-span's author
interview series